SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS NOW COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
HEARING ON THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS. AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES. HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE-
STREET BUILDING AND I'LL ASK FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- WHO
ARE HERE PRESENT IN TWELVE
HUNDRED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR
QUORUM. AND BEGIN OUR HEARING.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL TESTING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. WE WERE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPATION TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBERS.
844-291-6364 I'LL SAY THAT
AGAIN. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS FIVE TWO FIVE
FIVE ONE SEVEN THREE. FIVE TWO
FIVE FIVE ONE SEVEN THREE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES THAT WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE FOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THERE MAY BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE. FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTE IT AND
YOU'LL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
REMEMBER THAT WHEN YOU'RE CALLED
UPON YOU THE PHONE YOUR
LISTENING. IT'S IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE DON'T WANT
TO HAVE ANY INTERFERENCE.
OBVIOUSLY I MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING. SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR- IT'S ALSO A TIME
YOU'RE MY EVERYONE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY THAT THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMITTEE. AND PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO THE PHYSICAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL YOU ARE
TESTIFYING ON. AND PLEASE
REFRAIN FROM REPEATING YOUR
PRIOR TESTIMONY WERE NOT RE
LITIGATING THE MERITS WE'RE JUST
FOCUSING ON THE FISCAL IMPACT.
WE ONLY HAVE ONE BILL TODAY.
WHICH IS ELIGIBLE FOR A DO PASS
MOTION THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAS INFORMED US THAT THEY DO NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THE BILL. WE ARE
HEARING AND THEN A THEIR
REPRESENTATIVE WILL NOT BE
PARTICIPATING. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL LET'S
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CENTER
PORTANTINO I AM HERE PORTANTINO
HERE CENTER BATES. STATES HERE
SENATOR BRADFORD SENATOR JONES
CENTER JONES HERE SENATOR
KAMLAGER YEAH- KAMLAGER HERE
CENTER LAYERED HERE EARLIER HERE
CENTER MURKOWSKI HERE MY CASKET
HERE WITH SIX MEMBERS PRESENT WE
HAVE A QUORUM- NOW BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO THE BUSINESS I JUST
WANT TO REMIND EVERYBODY THAT
DUE TO THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS I RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
INSTITUTE A TIME LIMIT ON
WITNESS TESTIMONY SHOULD THIS BE
NECESSARY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED. A TOTAL OF FIVE
MINUTES FOR PRIMARY TESTIMONY
ALL OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THE
NAME AFFILIATION AND POT
POSITION ON THE MEASURE COMMONLY
CALLED ME TOO IF WE IF NECESSARY
WILL ALSO LIMIT THIS ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY TO TWELVE MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE AS REMINDER ALL
WITNESSES SHOULD LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL IMPACTS
OF THE BILL SO OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES ARE GONNA HAVE A TOTAL
OF FIVE MINUTES AND EVERYONE
ELSE WILL BE A ME TOO LIMITED TO
TWELVE MINUTES. AND I WILL TRY
TO STRICTLY ENFORCE THE ME TOO
PROVISION OF COMMENTS THE ONLY
ITEM ON OUR AGENDA TODAY IS AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GRAYSON AND
WICKS IT'S AN URGENCY MEASURE
THAT IS ELIGIBLE FOR DO PASS AND
SO- THE TWO OF YOU ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUES WELCOME AND PLEASE
TELL US ABOUT. AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND ESTEEMED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS JOINT
AUTHOR AND I ARE PRESENTING AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE WHICH
WILL EXTEND EVICTION PRO
PROTECTIONS FOR TENANTS WHO HAVE
FILED FOR EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE BY THE END OF THIS
MONTH SINCE THE RATE REALLY
PROGRAM LAUNCHED ONE YEAR AGO
CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE NATION IN
DELIVERING ASSISTANCE TO THOSE
THAT ARE MOST IN NEED AND RISK
OF LOSING THEIR HOUSING. THE
STATE PROGRAM HAS DELIVERED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN DIRECT
ASSISTANCE TO DATE HELPING MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
THOUSAND LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
PAY OFF RENTAL DEBT AND AVOID
EVICTION ONE IN THREE PAYMENTS
NATIONALLY HAVE BEEN MADE IN
CALIFORNIA TO TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS THAT ARE IN NEED BUT
IT IS TAKING LONGER THAN
EXPECTED FOR THE STATE TO
PROCESS THESE APPLICATIONS FOR
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE. THOUSANDS AND THAT
IS THOUSANDS CONTINUE TO WAIT
FOR RELIEF WHILE OTHER
APPLICATIONS PENDING IT WOULD BE
CRUEL AND IT WOULD BE WASTEFUL
AS WELL AS UNFAIR TO SUBJECT
CALIFORNIANS TO EVICTION OR THE
LOSS OF CONTROL IN NOW WHEN THEY
HAVE DONE EVERYTHING THAT HAS
BEEN ASK OF THEM AND THE
DISTRIBUTION OF EMERGENCY
RENTAL. ASSISTANCE IS IMMINENT
WE ARE NOT GOING TO ALLOW THE
CALIFORNIANS TO SUFFER TO LOSE
THEIR HOMES OR EVEN THEIR INCOME
BECAUSEOF APPLICATION
PROCESSING TIMES SO AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY NINE IS GOING TO
HELP US TAKE CARE OF THE
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
TENANTS AND LANDLORDS ALIKE WHO
APPLIED FOR COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND
STILL HAVE THEIR APPLICATIONS
PENDING. THIS WILL LET US
MAXIMIZE EVERY LAST EMERGENCY
RENTAL ASSISTANCE DOLLARS TO
PEOPLE- TO KEEP PEOPLE HOUSED
AND ALSO- TO KEEP THIS GOING TO
THE RAM THIS AND TO THE CHAIRED
BY MAY JOINT AUTHORS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBER.
AFTER HEARING US OUT TODAY. I
YOU ALL KNOW THAT WE HAD A
CRISIS LONG BEFORE KOPEN-
COVERED HAS EXACERBATED THAT
CRISIS AND IT HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
BROWN A BLACK COMMUNITIES AND I
THINK ALL OF US HAVE. HEARD AND
SEEN THOSE ISSUES IN OUR
DISTRICTS- AND THERE'S MUCH WORK
TO BE DONE SEPARATELY FROM THIS
BILL RIGHT AROUND MORE HOUSING
PRODUCTION MORE PROTECTION FOR
TENANTS THAT WE DO HAVE TO
TACKLE. YOU KNOW WHEN COLBERT
HIT THE STATE TOOK ACTION YOU
KNOW I WAS A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF
AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT- WHICH
THIS BODY PASSED- IN AUGUST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO ESTABLISH
EVICTION PROTECTIONS AND TO
ENSURE THAT RENTERS. I WOULDN'T
LOSE THEIR HOME BECAUSE THEY
WERE UNABLE TO PAY RENT DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC. AND AGAIN THIS IS
THIS IS HELPS OUR MOST
VULNERABLE FOLKS WHO NEED THE
ASSISTANCE MOST. OUR WORK IS NOT
DONE. AS WE SPEAK HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF RENTERS HAVE
APPLIED FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE
AND THEY ARE STILL IN THE QUEUE
AWAITING THAT ASSISTANCE. THAT
WILL EXPIRE BY THE END OF DAY
TOMORROW. AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THIS BODY BUT THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE VOTE
FOR THIS BILL TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE THAT ARE IN THE QUEUE GET
THE PROTECTIONS THEY NEED THAT
WE HONOR OUR COMMITMENT AS
GOVERNMENT WE SAY THEIR SYSTEMS
FOR YOU. THAT WE HONOR THAT
COMMITMENT AND WE SURE THAT THEY
GET THE PROTECTIONS THAT THEY
NEED AND YOU KNOW THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS
BILL BOTH IN THE ASSEMBLY- AND
OBVIOUSLY NOW HERE IN THE
SENATE- AND ALL RECOGNIZE AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS BILL IS NOT
PERFECT. YOU KNOW THERE'S
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PREEMPTION
PIECES WHICH WE DISCUSSED OTHER
COMMITTEES I'M SURE MANY OF YOU
WILL RAISE IN THIS IN THIS
CONVERSATION AND I HEAR THOSE
CONCERNS BUT IN THE END OF THE
DAY WE HAVE TO PASS THIS BILL TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE THAT ARE IN
THE QUEUE ARE PROTECTED FROM
EVICTIONS AND THAT THAT
LANDLORDS ARE MADE WHOLE THE
TENANTS HAVE A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEAD. SO THAT WE CAN THEN GO ON
AND ADDRESS THE BIGGER CONCERNS
AROUND OUR HOUSING CRISIS I
WHICH I IMPLORE YOU ALL TO DO-
AND WILL HAVE OTHER BILLS IN
FRONT OF YOU- FOR IT FOR SAID-
SAID WORK- BUT AGAIN I KNOW THE
BILL'S NOT PERFECT WE DO HAVE TO
PASS OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE TODAY
MY HOPE IS IT PASSES THE SENATE
GETS TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK IN
TIME. TO HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE- HOPING TO
MAKE IT TO BE MADE WHOLE BY THIS
BILL AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
GRAYSON IN THIS WEEK'S
APPRECIATE IT- I AM NOT SHOWING
ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY NINE. PLEASE COME ON
UP. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS DIFFICULTY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
WE'RE THE LARGEST RENTAL
PROPERTY ASSOCIATION THE NATION.
THE LARGEST PART OF OUR
MEMBERSHIP ARE SMALL MOM AND
POPS WERE ALSO WAITING FOR
FUNDING SO WE APPRECIATE THE
NARROW APPROACH THAT YOU HAVE
TAKEN- BY PROTECTING THOSE WHO
APPLIED. BY MARCH THIRTY FIRST
AND OF COURSE THE NARROW
APPROACH IN ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE STATEWIDE CONSISTENCY IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO. OUR
MEMBERSHIP THAT WE HAVE
CONSISTENCY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SO I THANK YOU. FOR MOVING THIS
BILL FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SIR ANYONE ELSE IN THIS
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE A MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE AND
CALL THEM FORWARD INDIVIDUALLY.
THANK YOU IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT ONE AND THEN ZERO IF
YOU AREN'T SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY NINE. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS BEING HUTCHINGS.
RIGHT PUBLIC POLICY GROUP I
CAN'T FIND SUPPORT- I'LL BE
HAPPY. ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT- WE'VE HEARD
FROM THE SUPPORT NOW MARKET WILL
GO TO THIS ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED. SEEING NO
ONE COME TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
ANY OPPOSITION. NOW WOULD BE THE
IN OPPOSITION. IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT ONE AND THEN ZERO FEAR IN
OPPOSITION AB. TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE. IN MY MOMENT WE DO
HAVE ONE IN Q. I WOULD PROVIDE
THEM WITH THAT MY NUMBER. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO. IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE. AND WE
WERE TO LINE TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ALEXANDER TURNED IN WITH
THE INNER CITY LAWCENTER- WE'RE
EXTREMELY EXTREMELY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPACTS TO ABOUT TWO
AND A HALF MILLION L. A. COUNTY
TENANTS FROM THE PREEMPTION
CLAUSE. WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU TO ALL
THOSE WHO SPOKE IN FAVOR AND
OPPOSED- AS I NOTED IN THE
OPENING COMMERCE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS NOT PARTICIPATING
TODAY. SO LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE TO ANY OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ABOUT
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE. MISTER
WHITE HOUSE. SO ON THE ON THE
FISCAL ANALYSIS THE MORATORIUM
IS GOING TO END ON HURSDAY THIS
BILL DOESN'T EXTENDED WOULD
WOULD IT SHOULDN'T WE
CHARACTERIZED AS FAR AS THE COST
TO THE COURTS WILL BE NO
ADDITIONAL COSTS BECAUSE ON ON
THE NATURAL PEOPLE IF YOU
WEREN'T HERE IF YOU HADN'T DONE
IF YOU HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING
PEOPLE WOULD BE ABLE TO FILE FOR
AN UNLAWFUL DETAINER IS ON THE
FIRST ANYWAY. IS THAT IS THAT A
GOOD CHARACTERIZATION OF THE
COST OF THIS BILL RIGHT. I
BELIEVE THAT WOULD BE AN ACT I
BELIEVE THAT BE AN ACCURATE
OBSERVATION ASSESSMENT OF THE
BILL YES AND ISN'T IT TRUE THAT
THE FEDERAL MONIES IN THE STATE
MONIES THAT ARE IN THE POT TO
PAY THE PEOPLE WHO HAVEN'T
RECEIVED THEIR CHECKS. THAT
MONEY'S ALREADY BEEN
APPROPRIATED THAT'S THERE'S NO
NEW MONEY TO HAVE TO SEND THAT
MONEY OUT THAT MONEY IS THERE
THE COST TO THE STATE HAS
ALREADY BEEN BORN ON DIFFERENT
BUDGETS AND WE'RE JUST. GIVING
MORE TIME FOR PEOPLE TO CASH THE
CHECKS. YES THAT'S CORRECT. AND
TO THE EXTENT. THAT THE
PROTECTIONS THAT WE GAVE. WERE
FOR PEOPLE. THE- PEOPLE NEED IT
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC PEOPLE
NEEDED TO PROTECTIONS TWO YEARS
AGO SO GOING FORWARD. D. WITH
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AS LOW AS
IT'S BEEN AND WE'RE READING IN A
NEWSPAPER BEGINNING IN APRIL
WHO'S NOT GONNA BE INCLUDED AS
SOMEBODY WHO CAN'T PAY THEIR
RENT SOLELY FOR THE PANDEMIC AND
OR CATCHING CATCHING KOPET
THAT'S THE CO WORKERS. I WOULD
SAY THE ORDINARY THE ORDINARY
FICTIONS THAT GO ON IN ANY STATE
IN CALIFORNIA DOES WOULD PRESUME
BUT BUT WE WERE ONLY PROTECTING
THE PEOPLE THAT WERE COVERED. UP
TO SOLELY BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC IS THAT IS THAT. SO WE
WERE PROTECTING ANYONE THAT
ACTUALLY FILLED OUT AN
APPLICATION AND THAT- PROTECTION
CONTINUES- WE ARE EXTENDING THAT
PROTECTION UNTIL WE CAN ACTUALLY
ON OUR WORD IF THEY'RE IN THE
EYE BLIND. THAN THOSE OF THE
ONES WE ARE PROTECTING RECTIFY
AND THE BUT THAT FISCAL AFFECTED
IS GENERATED BY ORDERED.
CONSTITUTED BY THE KOPET SOLELY
FOR THE CALL KOPET UNDER PENALTY
OF PERJURY WRECKED ON. THE FACTS
MAY HAVE BEEN- SO. THE BILL
CREATES WHAT THE STAFF REPORT
TALKS ABOUT- VIOLATIONS OF
PEOPLE MADE THAT THE ACTIONS MAY
BE TAKEN IN THE COURTS AND THAT
MAY BE A COSTS THAT HAVE TO BE
BORN IF SOMEBODY IS FILE
SOMEBODY'S WAITING FOR THEIR
CHECK AND- LOOK THEIR LANDLORD.
PATENT SIX ACTION THAT'S A STATE
YOU KNOW THE COURTS ARE RUN BY
THAT SO THAT THAT MAY BE A
MINUSCULE POINT. YOU FOR THE
BILL ALSO CREATES A DOUGHNUT
HOLE FOR. TILL JULY FIRST WEEK
WE'RE SAYING THAT THE WERE
PREEMPTING LOCAL CONTROL FOR
TILL JUNE THIRTIETH RIGHT SO
THERE'S A DONUT HOLE THAT'S
COULD BE CREATED. IS THERE
ANYTHING. THAT THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT THE STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ON JULY FIRST TO DO
THEIR OWN LOCAL ORDINANCES SAY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO THIS. AND
THAT AND THAT AND THAT FISCAL
EFFECT WILL BE BORNE BY. THE
COURTS RIGHT. CORRECT YES SO AS
OF JULY. FIRST ST LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN PUT FORTH THEIR
OWN PROTECTION SHOULD THEY SEE
FIT AND CERTAIN PROTECTIONS LIKE
THE CITY OF OAKLAND WHICH WERE
ALREADY EXISTING THOSE CAN
CONTINUE. THEIR CERTAIN CITIES
LIKE SAN FRANCISCO IN THE COUNTY
OF LA THEY DIDN'T HAVE THAT IN
PLACE SO THAT'S WHERE THERE'S
THE CONCERNS FROM THE CAMPS WE
LIKE TO SAY IN SOUTH COUNTY THE
COUNTY OF ALAMEDA ALTHOUGH SO
ALTHOUGH OAKLAND THE PASTOR OF
THE ORDINANCE THE WHOLE COUNTY
OF ALAMEDA CRACKED. YOUR CRACK
PASSED ME WITH THIS BEFORE
MISTER CHOOSE BILL WAS PASSED SO
THAT WOULD THAT THAT WOULD BE
NOT PROTECT. THANK YOU FOR THE
FISCAL ANALYSIS. MISTER LEONARD
I WOULD MOVE THE BILL. WE HAVE A
MOTION TO HAVE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS YES MISS
BATES A QUESTION OF TO WHOM.
DOES THE MONEY GO WHEN IT'S
FINALLY RELEASED AS A GO TO A
TENER THE PROPERTY OWNER. IT
GOES TO THE PROPERTY OWNER.
PROPERTY OWNER HANDLER THE LATE
YEAH A NUMBER OF THEM ARE
OPPOSED TO WHAT IS THE
PROTECTION FOR THEM. AW IN THE
MEANTIME JUST. IF THEY'VE MADE
THE APPLICATION FOR- DIVERGENCE
HE RELIEF. IF THEY'RE THEY'RE
AWAITING MANY OF THEM ARE
AWAITING FUNDS. RIGHT NOW FUNDS
AND IS IT ACCURATE I'VE HEARD
THIS NUMBER WHICH IS STAGGERING
TO ME. THAT THERE ARE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND APPLICATIONS
WAITING. IT SOUNDS LIKE OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT DEPARTMENT KING.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY REVIEW OF
FRAUDULENT APPLICATIONS. KNOWING
THAT THIS MONEY IS GOING TO
ACTUALLY GO FOR. A LEGITIMATE- I
THINK I THINK YOU ARE REYES
IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF WE NEED TO
HAVE A LOOK AT HOW THIS PROGRAM
HAS BEEN RUN AND ENSURE THAT IT
IS RUN EFFECTIVELY- THERE'S ALSO
BIG CONCERNS AROUND THE FACT
THAT- FOR NON ENGLISH SPEAKERS
IT'S BEEN CHALLENGING- AND THE
MONEY HAS BEEN SLOW TO GET OUT
SO I THINK. YOU KNOW WE AS A
BODY I THINK NEED TO. HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS TO ENSURE THAT YOU
KNOW IF WE ARE. PUTTING FORTH
SOCIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS THAT
WERE IMPLEMENTING THOSE
SUCCESSFULLY THEY WERE HELPING
THE FOLKS THAT WE THAT WE NEED.
AND INTEND TO. END SURVEYS THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THAT UP- AT
THIS POINT IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE APPLICATIONS IN THE
PIPELINE. HAVE ALREADY BEEN
REVIEWED IT'S JUST A MATTER OF.
ACTUALLY GETTING THE MONEY AND
WHICH WE ARE DOING THROUGH THIS.
AND ACTUALLY CUTTING THE CHECKS
AND SEND THEM OUT AND SO THAT'S-
THE PURPOSE OF THE EXTENSION NOW
IS ACTUALLY HONORING WHAT WE'VE
ALREADY APPROVED IN THE
APPLICATIONS. I THINK THAT WOULD
BE AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF.
INFORMATION TO BE PRESENT WHEN
THIS IS FINALLY VOTED ON THAT
THERE HAS BEEN SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY. IN SOME SORT OF
ACTUAL VERIFICATION TESTING THAT
THESE ARE ALL HAVE BEEN REVIEWED
IN ARE LEGITIMATE THE FRIDAY.
THERE'S GOING ON IN SOME OF
THESE PROGRAMS IS STAGGERING AD
WE HAD A- I THINK IT'S A CHANNEL
FOR NBC ARE- REPORT ON THAT
REGARDING THE MORTGAGE INDUSTRY
AND THE AMOUNT OF FRAUD. IT HAS
BEEN A- PART OF ANY ONE OF
THESE. VERY VERY COMPELLING VERY
VERY IMPORTANT- SUBSTANCE
SUBSTANCE. SUBSTANCE THIS YEAR.
I'VE GOT SUBSTANCE ABUSE SOME OF
MINE TOO BECAUSE I'M A BILL
ALLOWED BACK ANYWAY- VERY VERY
IMPORTANT VERY COMPELLING BUT
THEY'RE VERY COMPELLING STORIES
ON BOTH SIDES OF THIS ISSUE
WHERE WE HAVE PEOPLE LOSING
THEIR PROPERTY. ARE BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN PAID WE HAD A VERY
VERY. A TRAGIC REPRESENTATION
ABOUT IT HOUSING- JUST THIS
WEEK. A WOMAN LOSING HER
PROPERTY BECAUSE SHE HAS BEEN
UNABLE TO PAY HER MORTGAGE IN IT
IS FOR. INCOME FOR RETIREMENT
INCOME. SO THAT'S A PROPERTY
OWNER. WHO'S BEEN YOU KNOW VERY
COMPASSIONATE WITH HER TENANTS
BUT NOW. OUR COMPASSION IS GONE
MONEY'S GONE HOMES GONE
PROPERTIES GONE AND THIS IS
PROPERTY THAT SHE- DID. THAT
TALKING TO YOUR FAMILY. SO THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT ARE VERY VERY
TRY. TROUBLING INTO OF TRYING
TO. BALANCE HERE. IF YOU ARE
PROTECTED WITH THIS MEASURE IN
THE AND IT EXPIRES JUNE THIRTY.
IN YOUR THEN SUBJECT TO EVICTION
WHAT IS THE TIMELINE FOR THAT.
WHAT IS THE PROCESS WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO CORDON
EVICTING SOMEONE WHEN THEY'VE
EVEN BEEN GIVEN THIS TWO MONTH.
EXTENSION BUTTON BUT IT'S OVER
THAT WOULD PAY THE RENT. WHAT
HAPPENS THEN I MEAN I THINK IT'S
IN A SITUATION SOME HAS BEEN IN
THE QUEUE THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN
MADE A WHOLE RIGHT I THINK. THE
EVICTION PROTECTIONS WITH THAT
AND- AND THEY WOULD GO THROUGH
THE NORMAL PROCESS DEPENDING ON
THE CIRCUMSTANCES AND THAT'S AT
LEAST SIX MONTHS TO A YEAR
ITSELF. SO THEY COULD CONTINUE
TO OCCUPY THE RESIDENCE UNTIL
THE COURT IN ALL OF THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PART OF THIS WAS
BACK IN. RIGHT THAT IS CORRECT
THANK YOU. MISSED SOME LUGGAGE
HAVE A QUESTION YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'M GOING TO- TRY
MY HARDEST TO KEEP MY QUESTIONS-
FOCUSED ON FISCAL SINCE THIS IS
A COMMITTEE- SO IF I FALTER. YOU
CAN FORGIVE ME IN ADVANCE I DO
WANT TO SAY FOR THE RECORD THAT
GIVEN THIS IS APPROPRIATIONS AND
GIVEN THIS IS. ABOUT A FISCAL-ANALYSIS OF THE BILL DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SHOULD BE HERE
BECAUSE THERE ARE QUESTIONS THAT
FOLKS. HAVE WHERE WE SHOULD HAVE
THEIR INPUT AND SO THAT'S JUST
FOR THE RECORD. SO HOW COME OR
MAYBE IT'S ME. DOES THIS BILL
INCLUDE COSTS FOR STAFFING UP
BECAUSE TO THE PRIOR QUESTION WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE A HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND FOLKS. STILL IN
THE QUEUE AT THE STATE LEVEL WHO
ARE WAITING FOR THEIR MONEY. AND
WE KNOW THAT THE DELAY IN
GETTING IT OUT HAS BEEN FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS INCLUDING JUST
NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO
KIND OF PROCESS TO THE
APPLICATION SO DOES THIS INCLUDE
THAT. SO THAT HAS BEEN A PART OF
THE CONVERSATION AND THE
NEGOTIATION OF THIS BILL WAS THE
EFFICIENCY OF THE DEPARTMENT
ITSELF. AND WHETHER THERE WAS
ADEQUATE STAFF WHETHER THE
POLICY OR THE PROCEDURES AND THE
PROCESS WAS FLAWED OR IF THERE
WERE SOME CHALLENGES OR
OBSTACLES THAT WERE IN THE WAY.
THOSE THINGS ARE BEING ADDRESSED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION BEING THAT
IT'S THE AGENCY AND SO WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM ON
THAT THIS BILL HAS NOT
ALLOCATED. THAT TO MY KNOWLEDGE
IN THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
STAFF THESE THE MONEY THAT'S AND
THERE IS FOR THE RENTER AND
LANDLORD. SO WE'RE GIVING. WE'RE
EXTENDING TIME. TO HELP A
PROCESS THAT HAS BEEN SLOW AND
RIDDLED WITH PROBLEMS WITHOUT
ANY DISCUSSION ABOUT PUTTING
MORE PEOPLE ON BOARD TO HELP.
MANAGE THIS IN A QUICKER MORE
EFFICIENT WAY. IF I MAY- THE
FLEAS FIND A- WE WOULD ONLY-
ASSUME BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE AND AN AGENCY- AND
PEOPLE THAT RUN THE AGENCY AND
PEOPLE ARE IN PERFECT THAT YES
WE WOULD SAFELY ASSUME THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN PROBLEMS OR THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN- SLOW- ACTIONS
IN PROCESS HOWEVER I THINK
THERE'S SOMETHING TO ALSO
CONSIDER AND THAT WAS. THE LACK
OF FUNDING THAT WAS COMING IN
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE
KNEW THE MONEY WAS COMING BUT IT
WASN'T LANDING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA QUICK ENOUGH TO BE
ABLE TO DISPERSE INTO THE HANDS
OF THOSE THAT WERE IN THE
PIPELINE HAVING APPROVED
APPLICATIONS SO WHICH IS WHY
CALIFORNIA IS STEPPING UP TO THE
PLATE AND MAKING UP THAT
DIFFERENCE RIGHT NOW KNOWING
THAT. THAT MONEY I'M EMINENTLY
IS COMING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO NOW THAT WE HAVE
STEPPED UP WITH AN APPROPRIATION
WE CAN NOW MAKE IT POSSIBLE TO
HONOR THOSE CHECKS THAT HAVE
BEEN APPROVED. AND CAN I ALSO
JEFF JUST ADD- I KNOW THAT WERE
ALLOWED TO USE 10215% OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR ADMINISTRATION
I THINK IT WAS 10% FROM THE
FIRST PART OF MONEY- AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY THE APPLICATION
DEADLINE IS TOMORROW SO NOT
EXPECTING ANY NEW. APPLICANTS TO
COME RIGHT AND SO WE'RE PLAYING
CATCH UP HERE FOR THE NEXT
COUPLE MONTHS WITH THIS
EXTENSION- THOUGH I HEAR YOUR
POINTS AND I THINK WE ALL OF HER
THEM FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS AS
WELL AROUND THE FRUSTRATIONS OF
THE PROGRAM- SO I JUST WANTED TO
LET YOU KNOW WE CAN USE SOME OF
THOSE FEDERAL FUNDS FOR THAT
HAND. FOR STAFFING. WELL I MEAN
I JUST I SO I THINK THE
APPROPRIATIONS IS FINE. BUT IT'S
ALSO A MATTER OF LIKE MAKING
SURE THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS
PROPERLY. FUNDED SO THAT YOU CAN
DO THE BUSINESS I MEAN BECAUSE
THE NARRATIVE IN IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S FLUSH WITH MONEY.
AND SO WE COULD PROBABLY YOU
KNOW. HEY UP FIRST AND FIGHT TO
GET REIMBURSEMENT ON THE BACK I
FROM THE FEDS IF THE GOAL IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A PROGRAM
THAT IS PROPERLY FUNDED THAT IS
SCALABLE THAT IS GETTING MONEY
OUT TO CONSTITUENTS AND JUST FOR
THE RECORD I HAVE TO SAY IS VERY
HARD TO HEAR WHEN YOUR OWN
COUNTY CALLS IN TO SAY. THEY
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE BILL.
YOU KNOW IF FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THIS THING AT THE
STATE LEVEL HAS GOTTEN OUT TO.
YOU KNOW MAYBE REACHING TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND AS MEAN SO
THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING ABOUT THE
FISCAL PART OF THIS BECAUSE- IF
YOU'RE GOING TO DO IT WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO DO IT RIGHT.
AND I THINK. I SHARE THOSE
CONCERNS AND- YOU KNOW THIS
ISN'T A POLICY COMMITTEE BUT I
DO THINK. AS THOSE ARE THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS TO BE ASKING- AND
ULTIMATELY I THINK THE GOAL THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS GIVE
OURSELVES THAT TIME SAID THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION CAN.
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM SO THAT
THOSE THAT ARE ON THE HOOK WILL
BE MADE WHOLE- BUT IDO THINK WE
HAVE TO HAVE- SOME ANALYSIS
AROUND THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
PROGRAM. AND SOME LESSONS
LEARNED- THIS AND OTHER PROGRAMS
DURING KOPEN I THINK FALL IN
THAT SAME CATEGORY- BUT I SHARE
THE CONCERN AND YOU'RE NOT WRONG
TO RAISE THE FLAGS- BUT THE
POINT OF THIS BILLS TO REALLY
GIVE THE ADMINISTRATION MORE
TIME. AND A CITY MORE TIME TO
HONOR THOSE COMMITMENTS AND THE
OTHER THING I'LL SAY TO IS I
THINK THERE'S CONCERNS AROUND.
THE OUTRAGE OF THE PROGRAM RIGHT
WE DON'T HAVE AN EFFECTIVE WAY
TO COMMUNICATE TIS PROGRAM- AS
A GOVERNMENT THAT IT THAT EVEN
EXISTED. AND CRITICALLY FOR NON
NATIVE ENGLISH SPEAKERS AND
THOSE THAT MAYBE DON'T NAVIGATE
GOVERNMENT- IN THE SAME WAY
BECAUSE OF LANGUAGE BARRIERS OR
OTHER ISSUES. THAT WAS A VERY
REAL CONCERN AND IT IS BEEN
BORNE OUT WHEN YOU SEE WHO IS
ACTUALLY APPLY FOR THE PROGRAM-
SO THOSE ARE ISSUES THAT I DO
THINK NEED TO BE ADDRESSED. SO
HAS THERE BEEN ANY THOUGHT ABOUT
IF IT MAY TAKE LONGER THAN JUNE
TO GET TO THE FOLKS THAT ARE IN
THE QUEUE. I MEAN I THINK IT'S
OUR HOPE THAT THAT WILL GIVE US
ENOUGH TIME TO. TO HONOR ALL THE
COMMITMENTS THAT WE'VE HAD. I'M
AT THE THRESHOLD OF GOING BEYOND
THEFISCAL QUESTIONS SO I'M
GONNA RELEASE MYSELF FROM MY OWN
STRESS. THANK YOU. MISTER
BRADFORD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I TO- FOLLOWING LINES
QUESTIONING THAT- SENATOR CALM
WATER HAVE BECAUSE I TOO HAVE
BEEN CONTACTED BY MY COUNTY I'VE
BEEN CONTACTED BY A SMALL
LANDLORDS AND BEGAN TO HAVE THIS
MONEY AND REALLY THE STATE JUST
LIKE ET DE WHERE THAT ROADBLOCK
WE'RE THEY IMPEDIMENT AND SO
THAT BE FLUSHED WITH CASH OR
LEASE HAVING MONEY TO REIMBURSE
AND- MAKE FOLKS HOLD BUT WE
HAVE. NOT THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
DISSEMINATING GET THE MONEY TO
THE PEOPLE AND NEEDS IT IS
ALMOST LIKE A FACADE IT'S ALMOST
YOU KNOW THE ACTOR X. AND SO I
THINK STANDING UP THESE AGENCIES
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE
PROPERLY STAFF WILL ALLOW US TO.
DO WHAT WE ARE ALL OUR
INTENTIONS ARE TO MAKE PEOPLE
HOLE BUT WHEN WE DON'T HAVE THE
INTERNAL WORKINGS WERE GONE YOU
KNOW FIRST FIXED FASTER
FRUSTRATION WE'RE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE A POOR STAFFING AND POOR
PREPARATION FOR THIS SO I THINK
THAT SHOULD BE A PRIORITY I
THINK THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN SOME
OF THE- FIRST QUESTIONS ASKED.
IT'S INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE TO
GET THESE CHECKS TO PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT AND IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
STILL NOT IN PLACE. SIR BRADFORD
YOUR YOUR AGAIN RIGHT- ABOUT
YOUR COMMENTS- WHAT YOU'VE MADE-
HOWEVER- ALONG WITH THE CALL FOR
IMPROVEMENT AND MAKING SURE
STAFFING IS ADEQUATE. WE ARE
FACING A DEADLINE THAT COMES TO
US TOMORROW AND. IF WE DON'T
TAKE ACTION AND HELP PEOPLE SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY
TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT. AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
OUR STATE AGENCIES- AND IN DOING
SO WE NEED ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
WE KEEP PEOPLE HOLE ESPECIALLY
WHEN THEY'VE DONE WHAT WE'VE
ASKED HIM TO DO. NO I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND THE DEADLINE AND I'M
NOT CRITICIZING THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE TO TAKE ACTION BUT WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING WELL BEFORE WE GOT
HERE YOU KNOW AND MAKING SURE
THESE AGENCIES WERE. PROPERLY
STAFFED AND PREPARED TO DO WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE SO COMMENTS
WELL TAKEN. FURTHER COMMENTS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE VOTE
FANTASTIC THIS IS A TO PASS- A
MOTION WITH THE REFERRED THE
BILL TO THE SENATE FLOOR WE HAVE
A MOTION YES I MADE IT A WHILE
AGO MR LAYERED MADE A MOTION SO-
WITH THAT MISTER CONSULT WHICH
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
BATES KNOWS SENATOR BRADFORD.
RADFORD I SENATOR JONES JONES I
CENTER KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER II
CENTER LAYERED HI LAYERED I
CENTER Y. CASKEY HI MY COUNTY I
GO TO SIXTY SIX TO ONE THE BILL
IS OUT SIX TO ONE THAT IS OUR
ONLY A MATTER OF BUSINESS NO
NEED TO PUT IT ON FALLS ON TO
EVERYBODY WAS HERE CHECK WITH
THAT EXACT- I GOTTA GO BACK. THE
COMMITTEE. NO CLOSING COMMENTS
THANK YOU OFFER HERE- PROVIDING
YOUR TESTIMONY YOUR COMMENTS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND EVERYTHING
WILL BE INCLUDED IN THE RECORD-
AND SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THANK YOU WE'VE WRITTEN
COULD OF THE AGENDA AND THIS
COMMITTEE MEETING IS ADJOURNED.